we're now going to talk about the main
division that emerges in islam shortly
after the death of muhammad and that
division is between sunnis and shias
and this division even exists today
where roughly 90 of the world's 1.5 or
1.6 billion muslims are sunni and
roughly 10
are shia
and that 10
is concentrated mainly in places like
iran iraq but they are spread throughout
the muslim world or the world in general
now the word
sunni comes from the word sunnah which
is referring to examples of muhammad the
word shia comes from shiatu ali which
means followers of ali or party of ali
and we'll talk more about ali in a
little bit
but the general division is over who
should succeed muhammad after his death
as the leader of the muslim community
shias believe it should be members of
muhammad's family and especially
descendants of muhammad
while the sunnis believe that it doesn't
necessarily have to be that
but as we'll see this division becomes
stronger and stronger and stronger as
there's more and more bloodshed between
the two parties
because so much of this revolves around
the family of muhammad let's just review
that first and then we'll talk about the
division over who should succeed
muhammad as caliph or successor to lead
the muslim community so you see muhammad
right over here born 570 we have his
birth on our timeline as well and just
to read this timeline it goes from light
blue to dark blue when muhammad
according to islamic tradition starts to
have the revelations from god and the
muslim calendar starts at 6 22 at the
time of the hajira where the muslim
community in order to escape persecution
from the quraish migrate from mecca to
medina
now we've talked about several of these
figures in other videos
right over here you have muhammad's dad
abdullah who dies several months before
muhammad is born
you have amina here who is muhammad's
mother and she dies when muhammad is six
years old
then you have abdul muttalib who is the
head of muhammad's you could say
household and he takes custody after the
death of amina and he takes custody
until muhammad is eight years old when
abdul muttalib dies and then muhammad's
uncle abu talib takes custody
it's under abu talib that muhammad
learns his trade as a merchant and as a
trader
now later on we talk about khadijah who
is a wealthy widow in mecca
and she employs muhammad and according
to islamic tradition is impressed by him
and proposes to him and she's 15 years
older than muhammad this is her third
marriage and muhammad marries her she's
a significant figure in islam not
because she is muhammad's first wife
but also because she is the first muslim
now as you can see muhammad and kathija
they have several children and i list
one of them here fatima
because fatima ends up marrying abu
talib's son ali
and ali is the ali that we're talking
about where the word shia shiatu ali
comes from party of ali
because ali is considered the second
muslim he is one of the early followers
of muhammad as you can see he is
muhammad's cousin he grows up in the
same household with muhammad with abu
talib and he is also muhammad son-in-law
he marries fatima and they have several
children two of which are hassan and
hussein who figure very prominently in
the narrative i'm going to talk about in
this video and the next
now the other figures that you see here
you have abu bakr who was a close
companion of muhammad also one of the
early muslims and you can see he was a
little bit younger than muhammad
and they are connected through aisha
muhammad marries aisha after the death
of kathija and aisha is a significant
figure in early islam she's considered
to have a very strong personality many
of the hadith are narrated by her the
hadith are the muslim traditions and
accounts of muhammad's life and it's a
significant part of the religion outside
of the quran
and she is married to muhammad at a very
very young age and there's some debate
about how young she actually was but as
we'll see she also figures prominently
in this narrative and in the schism that
develops between the sunni and the shia
and the sunni and the shia view her
differently
so let's go back to the timeline here so
as muhammad's life nears its end in 632
in previous videos we talk about his
final pilgrimage to mecca and then on
his way back to medina at a place like
gadar kum he gives a sermon a sermon
that is especially very important to the
shia
according to that short sermon and
gather kum gather literally means pond
or small stream so it's the sermon at
the pond kum
there is one quotation that shia
considered to be very very important
where muhammad says of whomsoever i had
been mullah ali here is to be his moala
and the word mola means protector or
leader or it could mean guardian or
people that you are close to
and the shia view this as clear evidence
that muhammad intended ali to be his
successor
many members of the sunni tradition take
a slightly different interpretation
where they say mola doesn't necessarily
have to mean protector or leader it
could mean companion or friend or member
that is close to and so they don't view
this as strongly of evidence but in the
shia tradition the event at gadar kum is
actually a significant event and it is
even a holiday
so that's the evidence that shia point
to as why ali should be the successor
but then muhammad dies
and according to
the tradition
while his funeral was being planned by
his family the close companions were
meeting and discussing who should
succeed muhammad and the close
companions decide that it should be abu
bakr so abu bakr becomes the first
caliph and he rules for two years he
succeeded by umar sometimes pronounced
as omar
who then is assassinated
who is succeeded by uthman sometimes
pronounced as usman who is then
assassinated and then ali takes power
according to sunni tradition these first
four khalifs are considered the rashidun
caliphs or the rightly guided and under
their rule you have the significant
spread of what becomes this islamic
empire that we talk about in other
videos
in shia tradition they consider these
first three khalifs as usurpers they
believe that ali should have been caliph
from the beginning right in 632 at the
time of muhammad's death and once again
they cite the events at gadar kum which
was
observed according to the hadith by
thousands of people and there's many
many accounts of this
now ali is in power but as we will see
in the next video this starts the first
civil war the first muslim civil war
often referred to as the first fifna
between ali and the umayyads who are the
family of uthman and we will cover that
in the next video